good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toes happy Wednesday hump
day
thank you I didn't even realize it was
hump day thank you so much for a - its
what happy hump today everyone make sure
to hump someone you love I will be
spending the late afternoon humping my
dog Theo who's right behind me
positioned in his love sack he has been
loving the love sack recently due to
Theodora due to Theodora painted it to
Theodora crunchy angel Dora beautiful
precious Dora precious chairman Dora
this song like kind of doesn't work /
zoom I was listening to it back
yesterday and we were so off just want
you guys to know like when we do it IRL
when we're back in the studio like it
hits so hard it [ __ ] slaps like you
guys are in for a treat it'll give you
chills down your spine
how much dread it is 100% as you can see
behind me I am changing my sheets today
very exciting day over here in my
household how about you hang in there
it's a that's a big day I'm doing good
you know it was um yesterday was one of
the more difficult days in quarantine
for me um because we were so busy and
then like when I wasn't busy I was just
looking forward to like watching TV
mindlessly and I was just so bored like
I could not put one thing on the TV
without rolling over onto my phone five
minutes later and totally forgetting
about what was on TV I started the new
season of 13 reasons why and I want to
finish it cuz it's the last season and
there's a lot of controversy I've heard
a lot of people talking about it but I
literally couldn't get through the first
episode it was just so my numbing ly
boring and it's like fourth season again
like it's the same [ __ ] thing it's
like who died yeah no not for me I
actually did not have that issue
yesterday because I finished the book
for the redheads loved it fabulous book
and then I bench watched some more of
Real Housewives of Potomac and it's just
so good I finally have met and gotten to
know Monique Samuels and I love I Stan
and I ship her and Kris please don't
tell me like anything almost what
happened to
like I have no idea where the seasons go
I don't really know any spoilers so like
watching it all in having that's my
dream way to watch housewives is to
binge watch like episode after episode
which we don't get to do on this show so
I'm just truly having a ball and it's
like I have so many opinions about
things that happened I guess it's like
2016 2017 that probably nobody cares
about now but um I'm just loving it no
I'm so jealous of that like first time
experience you're having like you're
just like this virgin who doesn't even
know what's happening Monique was such a
fabulous addition to the show she is
just so gorgeous and her her and her
husband are so cute have you met Candace
yet I don't think so oh okay um I
thought they came on at the same season
but maybe they didn't I'm curious to
hear your thoughts on her as well okay
cool I can't wait I also like love that
Monique like came on the show moved to
Potomac on the show like bought a house
on the show it's the house that we saw
and I was like I need to be looking at
this house every day it's like such a
farm tremon vibe and I hope that they do
wind up moving into it it's just like
with housewives I always get a Pitt
because like it's like all happens like
before in the fall you know and then
there's a divorce and then everyone
loses all their money and like I'm just
really hoping that that's not what's
gonna happen for these women know also a
trend on housewives is that a lot of the
women live above their means simply
because they're on TV and wanna like put
forth this lifestyle and then that just
like offsets a spiral of financial
troubles we've seen it what literally
one too many times
but um you you'll say I don't wanna okay
it's I think I know like one spoiler
about Karen huger
but everything else is new to me so it
is so fabulous I am enjoying it so much
and I just like I'm trying to carve out
free time for myself
so that I can watch it but I'm strangely
so busy like we're recording the
redheads today it's just
and whenever we record the redheads it's
literally like a 12 hour job so um I I
need to find some time for myself and
the ladies of Potomac you know as
married women will never have that like
first dating someone like butterfly
feeling but like sometimes every now and
then you find a TV show that gives you
that feeling where it's like you cannot
wait to get home and watch TV like you
will push off all other plans like me
we're just you get this excitement and
I had that with Desperate Housewives and
I honestly haven't had it since and I'm
so jealous and happy for you that you
are having that butterfly moment yeah
every every time I sit down to the TV
like I know exactly what I'm gonna watch
I know them and I'm having a fabulous
time like I'm so excited to get to know
the women even more spend more time with
them like wine and dine also watching
reality TV while being in quarantine is
it's difficult it's rude like how much I
go out and have fun and you're at home
to the point where I want to go to the
restaurant
Oz and eat EMU and kangaroo because I
just want to go to a restaurant yeah oz
is an interesting place that was that is
like the craziest thing with a I'm like
okay she was like nobody wants the
kangaroo sliders no but you know there
is a Australian restaurant we're back
where he used to live I think it's
called Rudy's or Ruby's yeah it is I
know it's so popular like you know
completely every Sunday there was a line
around the box I never ate there cuz I
don't wait in line for food I just I
would rather go to like the worst
restaurant on the block if their seating
now like I'll never wait for food oh of
course but Ashley Darby should go down
to that restaurant and see what they're
doing and the fact that her husband like
won't budge on me I need about
Australian jack is like a really funny
interesting storyline you know like yeah
about their Australian restaurant that's
just a little too gamey he's just he's
so weird Michael like he he ruins and
makes the show like he's that polarizing
yeah so far so far I mean season two
he's a little um worse than season 1 but
so far like season 1 their marriage was
really sweet I thought it was it was you
know not what you would expect but I
thought that they had a really good
bedrock of um marriage and season 2 I
can see some of that starting to crumble
but I still think like I still think
they're gonna match but I know some
stuffs about to happen and I just like
just watch I know I know we have a very
busy long show because it's Wednesday
which means we're cueing deer toasters
we also are gonna recap the Vanderpump
rules reunion which aired last night and
talked about a lot of the Vanderpump
rules drama so it's going to be very
humble heavy episode I also watch
last weekend I never got a chance to
discuss the Jeffrey Epstein documentary
and I had so many thoughts that I would
love to share and I would love to hear
what everyone else thinks um and then
also we'll recap do you watch our
trapezoid last name I watched some of it
um and really go through the Jeffrey
Epstein documentary I just have like a
lot on my plate right now and
unfortunately um things are taking mr.
Epstein just got pushed to the side okay
well that's okay I'll fill you in um so
I think we should just jump right in
because we have kind of like a busy day
of stories we have a busy day of story
so without further ado here are the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast and thank you
Jackie
I would just like to take a minute I
have something really important to say
and it's important because I think I
will if I don't say it I might fall ill
with a case of RDH because I would be
remiss I would be devastated I might
even like not to be dramatic I might be
heartbroken
if I don't let everyone know that
today's episode is brought to you by
policy genius there's never a bad time
to save money but now more than ever
finding smart ways to put some cash back
in your pocket can make a huge
difference one way to do that is to
simply save on the things you already
pay for like home insurance if you own a
home reach shopping your home insurance
rates with policy genius could save you
a good chunk of change and the best part
is you barely need to lift a finger to
do it my favorite first head to policy
genius comm and answer a few quick
questions about yourself in your
property then policy genius will compare
your policy against options from top
insurers to make sure you're getting the
right home insurance coverage at the
best possible price if policy genius
finds you have a better rate than what
you're currently paying they'll do all
the work and get you switched if you own
a car to policy genus will compare your
home and auto policies around different
insurers and even mix and match to find
your savings they've saved their
customers an average of one thousand one
hundred and twenty seven dollars per
year just by doing that so if you'd like
to put a little cash back in your pocket
right now see how much you can save by
reach shopping your home insurance rates
at policy genius.com that's policy
genius calm thank you policy genius for
sponsoring today's episode let's dive
right in love it okay first story the
big story of today Vanderpump rules has
fired Stassi Schroeder and Kristen Doty
for racist actions one week at
after former Vanderpump rules cast
member faith Stowers revealed that the
two of the show's original cast members
Stassi and Kristen had reported to her
to the police for a crime she had
nothing to do with a Bravo spokesperson
confirmed to variety that Schroeder and
Dodie won't return to the show
additionally new cast members max boyens
and Brett Caprio knee whose past racist
tweets were uncovered after the most
recent season premiered in January also
will not return yet to me obviously like
Bret and Max getting fired was just like
so obvious they like when we when I was
watching last week the first part of the
reunion and they were talking about
their tweets and everything was going on
with George Floyd and the black lives
matter movement it just seemed so like
wrong I can't explain it so to me them
getting fired was like a no brainer
really mainstay is they didn't really
bring much to the show I don't think any
one was like championing them or their
character development I don't think any
focus groups were like we need to keep
these who on the show no the focus
groups were mad silent when it came to
Maxim Bret totally but the big news is
really Stassi and Kristen I think a lot
of people I don't know if people are
surprised expected this I don't even
know if I was shocked by this like I
feel like when I read it I was surprised
but then in thinking back I'm just kind
of like Bravo
how could Bravo not fire them like to me
and we're so anti canceled culture like
to the end but to me this is more
corporate culture like this is what
happens at a big company when employees
reflect poorly on the organization hi we
did that we got fired right I don't
think we ever expected them to not fire
us no that's that's what being in a
corporate environment that's what
happens to me though like I can't get
over how crazy this is really just for
Stassi like Kristine has had one foot
out the door like she hasn't even worked
out certain like five years I think that
if she mysteriously disappeared from the
show like maybe not that many people
would notice but Stassi has a lot of
fans and she's like really was one of
the people who kind of bled out for the
show and really she's one of the
originals I mean so didn't Kristen is an
original hasn't been
relevant in a really long time yeah well
I mean I kind of disagree because even
though Stasi is a big not even a big
part of the show like I always a bigger
star she's a bigger star for sure but as
it relates to the show like it could
have been conceivable for these two to
not be on the show next season
regardless of all of this so as much as
like so for the wedding except for the
wedding but I have to be honest watching
Jackson Brittany's wedding was the low
point of this season for me when
thinking back on it because when I was
watching the reunion and they're talking
about Tom and the best man I'm like oh
my god I'm not going there I'm not going
on her again and even the engagement the
four episode lead up to Stassi ambos
engagement like yeah I thought we wanted
to see them all grow up but now like
watching these activities it's just not
interesting and so yesterday before I
watched the reunion I was like you know
this is like they're just gonna overhaul
the show completely after this but then
I was watching reunion and even though
this season was not good and I think
also they're responding to some of those
criticisms from fans like this season
was not good like there has to be change
in the cast members I was watching them
Union I was like there is something
about this show that is inherently good
and interesting and entertaining Bravo
has a lot of like work to do and I think
that just firing these four people it
was a no brainer for them yeah but I
also don't know if it's gonna say she
ate those who critiqued Bravo because
Bravo has a lot of kind of problematic
cast mates problematic shows like
problematic moments like LuAnn showing
up in blackface and like it became like
a joke and it like no one ever really
spoke about it in a serious way and I
think that this was like a long-awaited
action from Bravo people have been
complaining for a long time about a lot
of cast mates from Bravo
not just Vanderpump rules and not just
diversity on that Vanderpump rules but
diversity and all the shows like our
cell is now the first black Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills how was that
possible there's been ten seasons like I
think that a lot of people might say
that this isn't enough yeah I would
agree with that and they're being very
public about the firing kind of like
they just don't want to be associated
with this but it's important to remember
that Stassi this isn't a story that
necessarily was hidden or got exposed it
was on a bear
public podcast people spoke about it in
2017 and Bravo did nothing about it
right so now I mean I guess they can't
not do nothing about it but to me like
faith had some other things to say about
some of the other people on the show and
and some characters and really the show
doesn't exist without um and Bravo
didn't fire that person you know so like
in when you put look at it all together
it's like this seems like the obvious
choice of course that they made and they
really didn't have to up heave the show
because these four characters are really
irrelevant to the way the storyline will
move forward after this reunion yeah but
also they it relates to Stassi because
she really is the biggest star she has
so much going on and this morning I was
gonna say like just because Stassi
started from dinner pimples doesn't
necessarily mean that she's cancelled
like she is a podcast she has a book she
has a second book coming out she has a
show in at or whether or not she's
cancelled will be her will depend on
what she does after this you know and
whether her fans are funding and
accepting and forgiving and willing to
give her some grace in some room to
continue to grow but this morning you
sent me something that was kind of crazy
that the pod cat her where her podcast
is hosted radio-cana or a statement that
they like are no longer doing straight
up with Stassi and the catalogue has
come down now I always assume that
Stassi owned her podcast and I still
think that she might maybe she's just
not with that network anymore and she'll
bring her podcast back I'll swear she
could do it on soundcloud podcasts are
free anybody can again for like in the
podcast industry everyone pretty much
and I don't know what her setup was so I
can't speak on it but if I'm assuming
it's like anyone else's podcast you'll
no matter how big or small your show is
you own your show you can move it around
but you need a network to host it to
distribute it and to sell it you could
have a podcast without all of that um
but I do I'm curious like where the
trademark he's like oh I have to assume
that she owns it I always assumed that
she did but now thinking back I feel
like she's been with this network I
think they rebranded a few years ago but
I think she's been with this network
likes
the beginning so I don't know if they if
she's just been maybe making a salary
from them yeah I mean we'll see what's
up in a year um but I do think a like a
big part of making a quote unquote come
back from something like this is really
all in how it's not always about what
you do it's about how you like try and
recover um and a huge part of that is
like a sincere apology and I really felt
like their statements kind of fell flat
and I'm sure they had to abide by a
certain amount of like legal rule from
Bravo but now that they're out of the
corporate America restrictions like I
will be curious to see how they both
kind of come back from this because what
they did was [ __ ] up and of course
people are entitled to make mistakes but
you're not entitled to forgiveness
without a true like apology and show of
remorse and I didn't really get that
from a written statement on Instagram
yeah I feel like obviously you know
whenever they do come back they will
have to apologize um but I did I
actually thought that some of their
statements were genuine I don't think
that you write like a whole paragraph
when it comes like from nowhere and you
don't mean it
Stasi literally said I am so sorry for
my actions and I do not expect
forgiveness like she knows that she
[ __ ] up they both do and I think they
understand the gravity of the situation
and that there's nothing that they can
say right now that will make it better
yeah who knows what will happen in a few
months from now um I assume that Stasi
would have her podcast and but now this
Morton like that kind of just like shook
things up for me um in what I thought
would happen from here on out yeah I'm
also they were playing before the
reunion they were being very Petty they
were playing like really old episodes
with the whole like Jax Tom Kristen
Stassi scandal from like seasons 1 & 2
and it was just like very ominous to
watch like it specially with the reunion
but also just watching this old episodes
like it was like borderline it was like
creepy like you know cuz you're just now
knowing what we know it just it seems it
seemed it felt really strange really
know we know and like in what way that
like in the sense that they're fired Oh
interesting
I even I felt that way about the
watching yeah watching the reunion I
felt that way too I would really like to
hear from faith oh she spoke she spoke
out I have her her quote Here I am page
six worded up I think she spokes then
she said that she feels vindicated after
the firings she said quote I feel so
vindicated studios and production are
able to see blatant racism and make
these positive changes and help move the
race forward help with the fight forward
she added that she had heard the news of
the firing just before she heard the
news of the firings she had been praying
for a family member quote I was in the
middle of prayer and I felt a sense of I
know it sounds corny I felt a sense of
glory
I felt God's presence and I'm seeing now
that the news has been revealed maybe
that is what it was he gave me a sign of
optimism and to be hopeful and showing
that all of this was worth it I mean I'm
sure she would never because she didn't
have you know many kind things to say
about Lisa Vanderpump but she deserves
some sort of like you know retribution
like she deserves to have been
successful on this show she was like set
up to fail yeah and maybe they'll bring
her back next season there's gonna be I
think next season American pearls is
gonna look a lot different than what we
saw last night do you remember um when
we recap this season finale and I said
that it really felt like a series finale
in some ways yes well I caught the tail
end of the episode before the reunion
started airing last night and then also
given what had happened like it really
felt that way like I feel like this show
is just first of all it's not very good
anymore it's deeply problematic and I
think it might benefit them like just to
get rid of it you don't think they could
just revamp it like on like with a whole
new next gen cast I think what people
kind of expect to happen is that it will
become like Tom Tom Tom Tom and Tom will
become almost like the Lisa Vanderpump's
of the next generation people will be
working in their restaurant and then you
can hire as many whichever servers you
want that actually sounds like a good
concept I never thought of it that way
yeah cuz there's too
to end the show I mean I don't know that
Bravo cares about the restaurants and
stuff but like they're like that is a
whole almost like this little industry
there's a lot exist jobs the show is
successful I think it's worth working
with that's what I I thought maybe if I
had in my last night's episode I
probably would have said just end the
show nobody enjoyed the season like
forget it but watching the reunion like
I realize there was something just
enjoyable about it and redeemable if
changes are made is how I feel yeah I'm
also really curious like what the fans
think cuz I was just like wanting to see
what people were were saying and
thinking about the firing and it was a
really like diverse group of opinions
like there are a lot of Stassi stands
that are just angry there are a lot of
people who have who have agreed with the
firing and think that it's long overdue
but that it's not enough there's you
know other problematic cast mates um I'd
be curious if they hear what the
toasters think honestly it's just so
crazy like we've been at we've I've
lived with this show for eight years and
it's like but this is just at the end of
the day like it's crazy but they
actually got fired it's crazy
okay next story switching gears a little
bit Coachella 2020 is reportedly
cancelled another cancellation after
massive staff cuts to parent company uh
after rescheduling it's April dates to
October due to the coronavirus lockdown
the end has finally come for this year's
Coachella Valley Music and Arts Festival
billboard reports this week the parent
company for golden voice AEG laid off 15
15 percent of its staffers furloughed
more than 100 people and issued pay cuts
according to an internal memo acquired
by billboard the memo also said it's
clear that live events such as Coachella
will not resume until 2021 quote when we
are able to reopen it will take time
until we see our fans partners and
sponsors fully return well I think the
first thing I want to say is I think
it's terrible that people lost their
jobs because that's just terrible and
this is just like a terrible terrible
time for for the job industry like it's
just terrible but I'm like low-key so
glad close jealous cancelled because I
don't want to go and like a part of our
job it was just to be like on the ground
a cool [ __ ] and we
now when two years in a row and like it
had its moments but like for the most
part like I sucking hate Coachella like
I'm just too fat to be there so I'm just
like this weight has been lifted will
not literal weight but like this
emotional burden of like thinking I have
to go to Coachella in October has been
lifted okay but what about stagecoach
I'm assuming yes in stagecoach too so
that is that is devastating but it's
it's collateral in my journey to not
have to go to Coachella like I'm
devastated but now I have to go to Palm
Springs not once but twice yeah you
would rather like not go to stagecoach
and have to go to Coachella in order to
go in a stagecoach but there are some
people whose like entire like fiscal
year revolves around Coachella and I'm
sure that they are devastated and I'm
sorry I'm sorry for you like I'm sure
this news is hitting everyone
differently yeah I don't know it's so
crazy because I feel like I used to
think about Coachella and I was I would
be like well it's just gonna keep
getting bigger and bigger and bigger
like when will it ever stop not that it
should stop but like you know they say
all good things must come to an end so
on the bubble bursts right I'm like how
it's just gonna keep going forever like
this but nothing is forever and now I
see like how and how it how all good
things come to an end
yeah I just feel like there are a lot of
brands that rely on festival season like
to exist you know like they're centered
around like revolve like there are a lot
of rare well revolve is bigger but there
are a lot of brands that like are I am
sure that a lot of their revenue is like
incumbent upon festival season and like
the whole festival vibe I just think
this is gonna you know hurt a lot of
different industries besides just this
particular event yes I would agree with
that but I think brands you know you
they spend a lot of money on Coachella
and then they make money but they just
won't be spending that money and maybe
they'll be saving maybe I just think
that this is so crazy because when they
announced like in March that Coachella
was being moved where it felt so far
away like no will be in the clear by
then and then slowly people were like I
don't know if October is gonna work I
don't know like Cooper is like comment
close and now it's like October is
around the corner and it's most
definitely getting canceled that it's
just I just
I can't believe how long this entire
thing has gone on when when we thought
maybe you know it was gonna be like a
month but now it's like it's gonna
probably like start to finish like
probably be a year but wouldn't it have
been canceled like is it if you have
these pay cuts and layoffs and furloughs
would it have been cancelled due to
coronavirus like restrictions and
gatherings in October I don't know an
interesting call I just think that no
live events are gonna happen in 2020
concerts whatever other live events
there are but you know anything like I
just I don't think I think Broadway
plans to come back in the fall I had
read um carnival Corps saying they're
coming back sports are working on coming
back I was watching Zach records this
show PTI and it came on like when one of
my programs finish it was just like on
the background it was quite interesting
um and they said that I guess MLB is
like having some issues the players like
you're gonna have less games but the
players want me paid the same and they
just I can't reach an agreement um
but sports should be coming back at some
point well I never thought I'd miss the
day where like Ben was watching four
hours of sports a night but I was just
like my ass like when I'm watching
better pearls being like well who's that
and then who's the one that got fired
I'm like just shut the [ __ ] up I'm
trying to like write notes like I'm
trying to listen I'm doing my homework
he's just like so chatty yeah yeah bring
back the sports okay
next story Caitlyn Jenner is celebrating
the five year anniversary of her
transition she says quote I have no
regrets we first met Caitlyn Jenner five
years ago this month
call me Caitlyn she declared on the
cover of Vanity Fair then she sat down
with Diane Sawyer and later appeared on
her own reality show I am Cait um she
talks about the process of transitioning
but she felt truly seen when she held
her driver's license photo in July of
2015 it was so emotional Jenner tells
people she did a People magazine
exclusive with some glamour shots um she
looked at her driver's license there I
was Caitlyn Marie Jenner
but then I wondered did Bruce deserve to
be thrown away like this he did a lot of
good things he raised ten kids but I
wasn't running I wasn't turning around
Bruce did just about everything he could
do he raised ten kids now what does
Caitlyn do when I look back on the last
you know 10 years of pop culture I think
that Caitlyn Jenner's interview with
Diane Sawyer was maybe one of the most
revolutionary and like groundbreaking
interviews of our time I feel like you
know I know that the transgender
community doesn't like live for Caitlyn
but she was a lot of people's like first
experience and first you know like
knowledge of the transgender community
and she really made it a global
conversation and I'll just I'll never
forget that interview like it was just
so there were so many rumors and like
nobody was like treating it like a
serious story and then she sat down with
Diane Sawyer and like it was a real
thing and you really got to understand
her whole life like over over 60 years
of like knowing that she was like in the
wrong body and it's just it honestly
it's still one of those things that I
just I remember where I was when I saw
it
me too I remember where it was when I
saw it I think it was one of the things
that had the biggest impact on pop
culture at least in my lifetime and it
was also one of the things that had like
the biggest impact on how I saw the
world like the 100% transgender like I
had never experienced or even met
someone who was transgender and to be
honest like that was the first moment
and I know that uh they didn't really
like love that she became kind of like
the UM the spokesperson for the movement
but in a lot of ways like she was a lot
of people's first you know moment where
they understood what it was like yeah I
I agree with that
it was I do think it's interesting
though that Caitlyn said in that
interview she has no regrets because
like maybe she would regret like
dragging Kris Jenner oh yeah and all of
the drama it's like they're part of it
do they talk where I don't know where we
ever like ended on that I think like
every day is different sometimes but I
do I do recall seeing photos
them you know at Nobu Malibu when
they're there for someone's birthday and
it seems like everyone is able to get
along I think that Chris is doing very
well in her life I think if there was
any fallout from anything that Caitlin
said about Chris that it has been mented
you know I feel like the Kardashians
actually do a really good job of moving
on from like really big things yeah and
it's been enough time has passed where I
remember those episodes where like Chris
was all distraught they were going to
the ESPYs like it was so fresh back then
but they've all moved on in so many ways
they all like so many more grandchildren
like I do think and I don't know them
personally but I do think that they have
moved moved past that drama and that was
also like pre Cory but now like Chris is
in this like net she's entered this next
phase of her life where she is just like
she is a definition of like the golden
years yeah oh my god no I'm like looking
forward to being Kris Jenner like that's
what I'm gonna be and no one is gonna
stop me that's like that conversation
they were having on the plane
trace and Chloe was like I'm going to be
Kris Jenner like my face will be pulled
like it was really cute I just in order
to be like my full Christian or self
like I need to be as rich as her so we
got to keep doing the show yep okay uh
next story Bachelorette alum Rachel
Lindsay hold on I'm getting an ad for a
subscription that I just don't want to
participate in Bachelorette of alum
Rachel Lindsay demands franchise address
systemic racism Lindsay the first and
only black read on The Bachelor
franchise since 2002 debut shared an
emotional blog post promising to quote
disassociate from the show if action is
not taken to diversify it it's mostly
white casting Rachel Lindsay on Tuesday
shared an emotional blog post calling
for the systemic racism within the
bachelor franchise to be addressed she
wrote quote recently I have received
many questions regarding the headline
stating that I will leave the bachelor
franchise if changes to wow I'm sorry
this website is just like all over the
place
what's website call it out it's a
Hollywood Reporter like it's not even
this is so not Hollywood
they remake it's you know it maybe it's
my iPad like
it's not it's not sure this is so not
Hollywood okay uh it's addressing
headlines God ah recently I've received
many questions regarding the headline
stating that I will leave the bachelor
franchise it changes to address the lack
of diversity in lead roles are not
established she wrote yes more diverse
contestants do appear on the show now
but is the lead truly interested and
open to dating outside of their race I
think that is evident by far how how far
their journey takes them during each
season it is my design I eat expectation
to believe that leads will authentic
least art an interracial relationship
for the first time on national
television the sad reality is that
people of color become placeholders as
the token person of color to add some
flavor to the second half of the season
Wow I mean that's she didn't lie no I
mean as much as it pains me to like
think of a world where Rachel NZ isn't
in the bachelor nation like I don't know
what anyone could do or say like for for
ABC and for Mike fights like to listen
like and I think that the platform
Rachel in you say this well yes sir like
the platform rachel lindsay has been
given is so important and she's the only
one she's the only black lee but she's
the only one really diving in on these
issues and it's just like it's it's
honestly like so late like come on yeah
I would at this point especially I mean
even when we were reported on this
yesterday um and again today like if
they do not make a change for the
upcoming season like I will truly be
shocked I will be shocked too but you
know what it's also like it's on us to
demand it of them but then also when
they if if and when they do cast someone
who's you know uh maybe a person of
color or someone who an Asian person
like anyone it's on us to watch because
there's their ratings driven so it's
important that like we obviously demand
it from them but then we also follow up
with the ratings because whatever
whatever is successful is what they will
do right I completely agree that's a
fabulous point I just like I don't want
Rachel Lindsay to leave bachelor nation
like I think she's so important but at
the same time like she needs to make her
point and yeah I support her I said
her as well completely but she does the
the The Bachelor podcast like she
actually hidden there she is she is her
hand and everything like she does sports
she she has another podcast like but
she's pretty like involved in The
Bachelor stuff yeah so it'll be a huge
loss for the entire bachelor nation if
she decides to step away I agree they
even had her on last season when they
address him on the comments that the
girls were getting and like the bullying
within bachelor nation cheez-its like
him she is an amazing role model yeah
and I think I think we'll see what ABC
does I don't know like when they would
announce anything like this but I have
faith that they'll do the right thing
now III hope well this is like where
we're at the crossroads like and when
when talking about Bravo it's like are
they just gonna do one thing to like say
Shay people are they gonna really an act
real change so it's like Bravo firing
Kristen and Stassi like obviously it's a
step in the right direction but they
solve a lot of problems at the network
and it's like what is ABC gonna do are
they gonna like put on a show and just
pretend like they're listening to the
people are they actually gonna listen to
the people yeah we'll see I agree okay
well fifth and final story is a little
beverage noon I pineapple Pepsi is now
available in the US after gaining
popularity in Japan Pepsi is known for
introducing exciting flavors and the
latest one sounds like the ultimate
summer drink Pepsi with a splash of
pineapple juice was recently spotted at
Walmart a pineapple flavored Pepsi was
first released in Japan in 2019 two
major success although it's unclear
whether it's the same recipe hell to the
no to the no no no hell to the no no no
no absolutely not this is and you know
I've actually recently made the
transition we are no longer a diet coke
household I love it actually did this on
the show officially haven't you haven't
you have we have recently transitioned
we are no longer a diet coke home we are
Diet Pepsi home and to be honest it's
something that was like eating me up
inside for like ever and the person
really the only person I ever really
told was Margo and she kind of agreed
with me it's like of course I'm from a
branding perspective like Diet Coke is
like chic and sleek
yeah it's like a vice level from a taste
level like Diet Pepsi is so much better
like it's sweeter like it's literally
just better and I feel like when I used
to go to restaurants and they were like
oh we don't have Coke is Diet Pepsi okay
I would be like yeah and secretly like
really excited about it and I just
decided to like not be embarrassed of
who I am and just lead with lead with my
heart and so you know we have tons of
like bottles and cans of soda in our
house and we've recently changed over
completely we are a Diet Pepsi home we
are coke free house and it's it's been
really fabulous I'm not gonna lie I'm
not even like embarrassed anymore Wow
I'm so proud of you that your coke free
um I
coke I'm three months off coke I happen
to disagree with you because I I truly
love the taste of diagram but I do I do
I do see you and I love that you're
leading with your heart and leading with
honesty and like stopping - pretending
to being someone that you're not yeah I
feel like I spent a like a huge time
part of my life like just trying to be
like cool and like do what I thought
everyone wanted me to do and that stops
today well you know what I'm just proud
of you for standing up for what you
believe it's Klaudia that's beautiful
what a perfect place to end and dive
into our TV recap segment or do toasters
which next TV recap yeah I love to end
on near toasters it's such a high okay
let's start with Vanderpump rules I just
have to share a really funny anecdote I
had like been watching for one minute
when Olivia FaceTime me to like tell me
something and then she had to go she's
like all right I gotta go to pump and
I'm like the restaurant rules and I
realized that she was pumping her
titties um but I just thought that was
like a funny moment to share yeah that
is funny okay so I watched last night
and we should recap the first one - I
had notes from the first one and then I
sign it and take notes but um I took
notes last night and I only had one note
from the first part which I honestly
couldn't believe that Max and Kristen
hooked up oh yeah that was crazy crazy
oh my note it for that is I actually
weirdly ship max and Kristen I think
that they like kind of make sense
as a couple my other note was that I
don't get Max and Deena at all she talks
about him like she never stopped having
feelings for him but on the show she
made it seem like she was all in on
Brett like saying she wished that she
met right before max but then like under
union it was like max was her you know
she never seen his face for they had
reconnected after filming her and Max
but like on the show so then she lied on
the show saying that she wished she met
right before max ik maybe she really
felt that way at the time but like max
like like technically she was the one
who broke up with max but then like max
like wouldn't take her back like Mack
with max was one who like put the nail
in the coffin um and so I'm sure she
like really did want to move on with
Bret but she just got like screwed like
everyone was being mean today that I
don't know I feel like she didn't she
either really had like strong feelings
for both of them or it was just like
acting her way through it to like have a
romantic storyline on the show no I
actually really believe like she wanted
things to work out with Brett with Brett
in the moment or max now in the moment
she like when she said that she like I
wish he had met Brett before max like I
feel like she really meant that I guess
I don't know and then my other note I
changed my mind all the [ __ ] time
like everybody's like hey none of it
like reads is genuine to me um my other
note was that Charlie when Charlie was
fighting with everyone um I said that it
felt like a bachelor reunion when people
are like who are irrelevant are trying
to audition for paradise simply trying
to like speak up and come for like the
big dogs so that land has like viral
moments so that they're like interesting
enough for paradise even though it's
great good person yeah I think that
there's something spunky and funny about
Charlie and I'm not not here for her in
general but it's just like her coming
for like old man Jack's and just like
how do you guys even know each other you
know they don't not was the point but
like that was definitely her trying to
have like an Instagram of a moment like
and now she's gonna make t-shirts like
old man retire yeah that's like such a
bachelor sent home night one thing to do
okay so I want to run through the
storylines from last night because I
actually found a lot of them to be very
interesting in the first one I want to
talk about um was when they were talking
about Sheena and Dana and Sheena like
the whole season was like really mean
today and especially in the beginning
when she
started but I feel like maybe I'm just
becoming like a Sheena apologist but I
feel like she gave an actual really good
explanation she said I'm so tired of
like being the one person who's nice to
all the new girls and she didn't say it
outright but it's like honestly and she
said that like Dana reminded her of like
Lala and Stassi and it's like she was
really one of the only ones who was so
nice just to Lala and then like Lala
like totally surpassed her and I became
friends with all the OGS and like she's
now considered like a cool girl maybe
she just didn't want to have that happen
again and I kind of understood it I
understood that until someone was like
yeah but you were so nice to Charley and
like we're up here about obsessed with
her so it was just you taking your own
[ __ ] out on Dana who even though Mike
she might remind you of someone else
like she's her own person and you were
mean to her and that's on you yeah I
just got the vibe that like dana
reminded Sheena of Lala a lot and she
didn't want to like remember when when
scheana was crying at that birthday
party like two seasons ago because all
the girls were becoming friends with
Lala and she was right
yeah no I think it's it's not that Deena
reminds her Twila it's like she saw
immediately that dana is just like
everything I'm the sword and she's like
another one's like I'm not gonna prop up
like I know you'll get there on your own
and I'm not gonna be stepped on on the
way so even though I love Dana and I'm
not for anyone like not being nice to
the new girls I like kind of understood
Sheena's like twisted thinking yes I
agree with that in the words of Lisa
Vanderpump I certainly don't condone it
or I don't condone it but I understand
it okay what did she say that um she
said that about oh that's so funny I was
it's from an old episode I was watching
it was when um Tom and Jack started
fighting at Sheena's engagement party
because accident yeah yeah I watched you
right before the reunion so it was like
fresh in my brain that's crazy at
Sheena's engagement party like and Shane
is like in the corner sobbing after
singing good as gold it was honestly
iconic like those were the days yes
exactly like I feel like because we had
those days everyone thinks that like we
need to and also this is this and then
another point I just have quickly
because we had all like all about
history people think that like we need
to continue on this journey but like
know at a certain point you graduate and
you can graduate from Vanderpump rules
and go on to you know do other things
also I feel
like something that maybe under pump
roles great but ultimately is kind of
like the demise of what we're watching
that was like all of the existing
history between all of the cast mates
that like they had these long
friendships and so even when they would
fight over a petty [ __ ] they would
always see no like they are a sisters
like Kristen and Stassi and hooked me up
with Jackson like you couldn't
understand it but they have this like
deep friendship I no longer feel that
that is important in order to have a
successful reality show cuz like
sometimes those long friendships develop
on a show because these are people who
are gonna be in your life every day but
like you it's just even like watching
Potomac like some of the new peer
meeting each other for the first time
and like they're having like castmember
altercations like that's interesting too
so I feel like they were harping so hard
on like these historic friendships until
they're driving them into the ground and
then wondering why we're not friends
anymore yeah the other interesting thing
that happened was um Sheena and Max
admitting that when they went to Palm
Springs like she they had meds made out
and like she tried to give him a [ __ ]
and again a machine apologist but I
could not apologize for this like her
that was when max and Dana were like
working things out yeah like just
because you're comfortable with someone
else's boyfriend like doesn't mean that
that is okay behavior that was just oh
and the fact that like she can't just be
like in that moment like yeah I still
have feelings for max I had him in my
bed and I wanted I was yeah I was just
like having a good time instead she's
like it's just like dribble like you
know the way that she responded and like
wasn't even apologetic to Dana like that
really bothered me like actually not
taking accountability at all that's the
definition of not when people say own
your [ __ ] like that is a perfect example
instead of staying making excuses like
oh my god was just country like best
friends you say no listen truly in my
heart like I still have feelings for max
he was away from you for the weekend I
didn't like you I know you guys are
seeing each other but I want to hook up
with him so I did yeah I was like
disappointed in her like Cavalier
response like that's the [ __ ] that
people hate when she pretends like she's
okay just fell into each other's penis
and vaginas totally tripped um this
segment where everyone was talking about
James of sobriety and like everyone was
really emotional like even Jax I think I
was like Janica yeah like I thought that
was fabulous me too and I felt as though
my opinions throughout the season were
validated as well especially as it
related to Raquel
um because I feel like we've been on the
show on and off for like three years now
no one ever paid her much does this
season like something about her was just
really endearing and it was nice to hear
that even like Stassi felt that way too
um and Stassi was like I never took the
time to get to know you but you're
actually really likable um and that was
the experience that I was having while
watching the show it's like Oh Raquel is
been around this whole time and I
there's there's something to her that I
like so yeah it was a nice story arc and
like to see everyone be so proud of him
except for Kristen
uh I like the secure one at the end of
the day like if Katie Maloney can
forgive James Kennedy like anything is
possible it's deeper for Kristen she's
to date him oh you know I'm not talking
about Kristen I'm just saying in the
grand scheme of the world like if you're
mad at your friend like just remember
Katie Maloney forgave James Kennedy but
I just feel like she she's moved on but
she hasn't like it's I feel like it's
still top of mind I feel like I have
people like that in my life where it's
like yeah we're cool I remember every
time I see you I will think about thing
that you said and that's yet I'd love
that everyone was giving like Raquel the
utmost respect like finally I feel like
she felt so vindicated after the reunion
but what bothered me is like they they
mentioned the whole Lala Raquel fight
pitbull I'm a Rottweiler and like how
awful all I was like literally like that
was the the most disappointed I'd ever
been in Lala like she was just such a
mean girl she didn't say sorry last
night like she just acknowledged that
she's like yeah like sometimes when I'm
getting the angry like I just say things
like I can't like she didn't say sorry
well I had seen an Instagram post after
that episode aired and it was a picture
of her in our cowl saying that she had
apologized and that like she was so
sorry and so I think like we all I mean
Instagram isn't the same as Iranian it
should have been addressed but maybe it
was cut out like I think that she was
sorry um and maybe that was just like
cut for brevity but yeah that was as a
Lala apologist even I couldn't ya
condone that or understand it
and to see her like be so hard on
herself and recognize that in her and
what I thought she said that was so
poignant when she was like I thought
that getting sober would like fix a lot
of those things I thought these things
were happening because I was drinking
and now I'm realizing that it's
something within me that I need to deal
with I thought that was really brave of
her to say yeah um and she was really
really sorry for that awful thing she
said about scheana on a Bravo after-show
that like I had never heard and I'm glad
that they clipped it because it was
vicious it was vicious so when we rolled
in a crop top and a Jojo CY ponytail
likes a tattle-tale like yet it was
vicious she felt really bad um and you
know this was something that I saw in
Potomac and I feel like it's the same
thing that happened here cuz I'm Potomac
this season two storyline gizelle had
gone on watch what happens live instead
the thing that Cherise was dating a
fireman to remember and was a huge fight
and like no one can understand how or
why she did that I feel like sometimes
when my gear show is just filming her
regular life but then you go to New York
City in your and watch what happens live
and you're on this set and like your job
is just like these celebrity and like
talk [ __ ] I think that sometimes they
get carried away I think that's what
happened with gizelle she was just like
feeling fabulous and like oh people want
her to spill the tea here I go and I
think that same thing happened with
Lala's like oh my gosh people love me
because I'm so like honest and and can
be harsh for people like that sometimes
I think she just got carried away and
like didn't know where the line was and
that she had crossed it maybe but it was
also at that moment when she started
getting emotional about scheana where
Stassi definitely did not realize that
they were recording her and she
whispered to Beau well I might be
bipolar yeah that was weird
yeah and like I'm necessary I I don't
know it was like mean because they're
friends it was obvious that she didn't
know that they were gonna include that
and it was just an all-around strange
moment yeah very freeing then it's like
yeah that's not appropriate the the last
two things I want to say are one I can't
believe there's a part three I thought
it was over last night I can't I was
shocked I can't believe there's in heart
three the second thing is the absolute
best part of the reunion was that it was
seven o'clock in New York and you could
hear the clanging of the pots everyone
clap
at seven o'clock for the healthcare
workers and then all the cast members
started to clap and I just thought that
was like so cute and I loved I loved it
yeah I'm weirdly I'm very into the zoom
reunion because you can hear what
everyone is saying it's let it's way
more structured and I just like I think
they've done a really good job with it
and also like they can mute people it's
like they could take you know when
you're like doing a podcast and you have
two different audios and someone's
talking over someone else you could just
take one personality can hear the other
person clearly like they're able to do
that and I think that we're getting like
a lot of better conversations I just
want to say like towards the end when
and they showed for next week where it
gets between Britney and Jax and Tom and
Ariana like I can't I no longer can I am
unable like I am NOT interested it is
the the lowest hanging fruit of
conversation and that's where it's like
I don't care that you've been friends
forever
you two are toxic as friends please stop
being friends like I don't I'd never
want to have this fight again on my
television and so I don't know who needs
to leave the show and I honestly I don't
know how there's really a role for
Britney and Jax um in like a next season
especially now that saucy beau Kristen
are gonna be gone if it's really focused
on Tom and Tom like we're do Britney and
Jax fit in they don't have a restaurant
right so I just like I can't yeah it's
um I'm not looking forward to that
conversation either I just couldn't
believe there was a part three I'm like
this is enough like how long are we
gonna beat this dead horse yeah um I
mean the else want to say about the
different roles before we move on no I
think I think that's it I want to
quickly talk about the Epstein
documentary and I will not spoil
anything for you so just keep your mics
on because we watched um I watched all
four you watched how many I watched you
I'm in the middle of three what I liked
but I'll start with what I liked what I
liked was that they really harp time
like how nobody knew what he did nobody
in the industry nobody in business and
then in the public we're like who is
this international man of mystery like
how the [ __ ] does he make money right um
and I appreciate that the inside look at
like all his different homes but I was
like kind of disappointed that it was
only
for parts when I feel like they really
didn't get into the celebrity element
like you know people on Twitter have
like found like all the flight logs like
all different types of celebrities who
were there and I felt like we could have
done more on that it's like we got
[ __ ] eight parts for exotic Joe
exotic the tiger came but like four
parts for Jeffrey Epstein honestly I was
just felt I was left wanting more yeah I
I think what I haven't gotten there yet
but that would bother me what it also
taught me and what I learned I forget
which documentary I think it was a the
Gabriele Fernandez one it's like the FBI
sucks like when when somebody gets FBI
involved it's like alright let's just
quit now because they never get anything
done this is the theme of everything
that I've watched in quarantine
the FBI sucks and I know you're watching
hi looking at my camera they adjust
they're constantly getting it wrong
Waco you have to think you know no those
two original girls who were in the first
episode who reported it in the 90s like
shame on the [ __ ] FBI like look how
long he went on they reported in the 90s
and then the early 2000s in Palm Beach
FBI did nothing it went on until 2019
but it's not like it wasn't reported
like everyone just [ __ ] ignored it
like and it's so deep-rooted and I feel
like they just didn't even get into how
deep-rooted
Geoffrey Epstein's like friends and
business partners were like I don't
think that's what I was missing like I
don't feel like they exposed enough
people yeah I like I haven't gotten
there yet but I'm sure I'll feel the
same way you know he's just like the tip
of the iceberg and they didn't they
didn't know like didn't even investigate
like the death at all they were just
like and then he died the end like it
was just I needed more yeah I feel that
okay well that's it that's it dear
toasters because my ear pads just made a
sound
oh but also really quickly the watch
happens live special from last night I
just absolutely loved it I I wanted to
just quote one thing that W kamau Bell
said which really um resonate
me and I feel like might resonate for
people in who are listening cuz and he
was like what do you say to white people
who like maybe are afraid to get
involved in the conversation for fear of
saying something wrong or you know are
afraid to just like talk about it
because it's uncomfortable and W kamau
Bell was like you should be like you're
probably gonna say something wrong
you're not gonna get everything right
but say sorry when you say something
wrong and then move on don't be afraid
to speak up because if it just
understand why what you said was
problematic and move on and I just
thought it was like a great like human
way of talking about this issue and I
loved it and W kamau Bell what's like
living for Porsche I like Porsche it was
just like Andy with that skirt question
and she went on like she just didn't
stop and W come out was like literally
in his little zoom box like yes yes like
it was just she's just everything and I
said it before but like she's just
making her grandfather proud and she's
still like funny and entertaining and
glamorous while also being so smart like
I just think like she has really
cemented herself like in the housewives
Hall of Fame for me and in like the
human being Hall of Fame yes those are
my two notes great love it
dear toasters is our advice segment if
you ever want to write and please email
us dear toasters at gmail.com we always
keep it anonymous so you don't have to
worry about that and we will talk about
anything from boyfriend troubles work
troubles quarantine troubles anything
dear toasters at gmail.com let's jump
right in
hi ladies so my boyfriend of seven years
went out was a friend one night he was
messaging me when he left his house and
said he was going to hang out with his
friend I assumed he was gone his
friend's house since I told him to stay
there for the night as drinking is
involved after a few messages I never
heard back I texted him asking if he
made it to the friend's house okay
nothing me being the anxious person
person that I am I began to watch his
local his watch his location and so he
was at a local strip club in the area
now a little backstory we've had a
conversation before about how I feel
about him going to strip clubs I told
him I wasn't sure how I would feel if he
ever went also there have been trust
issues in the past
anyways he stayed at the club for 30
minutes after after the strip club
closed and then he went home I called in
the next morning and he was asking and
was asking him about his night and after
questions I'm sorry I can't talk anyways
he stayed at the club 30 minutes after
the strip club closed and then he went
home I called him the next morning and
was asking him about his night and after
question dodging he confessed that he
did go to the strip club he
that his friend and him stayed until it
closed and then went back to his
friend's house and then went home after
speaking with his friend's girlfriend I
found out that this friend actually left
the club after arriving because his
girlfriend cussed him out so my
boyfriend was alone at the strip club
for hours and stayed after it closed and
then lied about his friend being there
with him and lied about going to his
friend's house afterwards he just went
home because I have his location my
question for y'all how do you feel about
strip clubs and relationships also am I
overreacting about the situation he said
the reason he lied to me because is
because he can't do anything right in
this relationship I love you and thanks
to the podcast during these hard times
it was a very bad that way a piece of
work he is yeah it can't be that hard to
like find out where your boyfriend is
you know no and you know what like if
you can't trust your partner like you
don't have a a good relationship um
the fact that he would lie straight to
your face and by the way the way I feel
about strip clubs like if Zack wanted to
go to a strip club with his friends or
he was going like he would tell me and I
would feel great about it like what in
entropy would and yeah oh my god no I'm
too insecure like I love shrimp clubs
like 11:00 in Miami's my favorite place
and like Ben knows like I'm allowed to
go but like he is like must sit in the
corner no but like if Emma we're on the
bachelor party and like the group were
going to a strip club you're gonna tell
your husband that he can't go yes I I
just don't want him knowing that there
are like breasts out there that are
genetic in mind you know but like he
knows that already no he doesn't he
doesn't know he knows no I'm sorry like
it's just a big but you know what like I
not to be like so bragging and Whang but
like Ben is like so sweet like he would
literally never go and if he did like he
would Larry send me like he would send
me a video of himself in the corner like
because he's like a weenie
so I don't have this problem but I'm
sympathizing for the girl that does and
to be honest the problem isn't that he
went to a strip club it's really that he
lied about it yeah like if your man is
going to strip clubs and lying like you
have a problem he's going to strip clubs
with his friend he's telling you and
saying babe like the boys are going for
strip club like do you mind if I go and
you like say yes that that's healthy
like strip clubs are always gonna be
there and then are going to want to go
but it's just the way he went about it
that he lied to you that he makes you
feel crazy that he said he can't do
anything right in this relationship like
playing the victim like I'm sorry but I
hate your boyfriend yeah
your boyfriend but for girls who maybe I
actually totally rethought my my stance
on strip clubs for girls who may not
want their husbands or boyfriends go
into strip clubs I think a fabulous
thing is to offer to go together because
I've actually now that I think about it
I don't know if I've ever been in a
strip club without been and I've been at
a lot of strip clubs all over this
country in New Orleans Florida New York
tons places so I think that's a great
it's a great bonding experience
I agree but like when we were on we were
in Miami we went to 11 just girls like
mm-hmm if Ben were in a bachelor party
in Miami and they were going to 11 what
would you have to say 11 I think is a
different conversation that that's what
I'm referring to when the exact when I
don't watch her party and he was like
we're gonna live and I was like have a
great time
I wouldn't include that because 11 is
like the best club in Miami that also
happens to like have strippers but it's
not like a place devoted to stripping I
feel I think that they can't talk I
don't think we can use that example I
don't okay if they work out okay say
they were in a bachelor party in
Scottsdale and they were going to the
strip club but like that's what you do
on a bachelor party no I know I just
like worth say they were in Vegas and
they're going there on the strip they're
going the strip you know I don't know I
feel like you'll just have to ask me on
the day like depending on how I'm
feeling you know I would either be like
yes Ben get them titties or literally
I'm gonna strap you to this chair and
it's like if you have plans to go into
the strip club like sometime soon like
you better make the week before count
you know you better keep me in a good
mood so that I'm like fabulous go I'm um
I don't think I can make blanket
statements because my opinion is
changing so much as I'm talking about it
and I'm sure would just be like on the
night and it's like if I have fabulous
plans like you can go do whatever you
want but if I'm sitting at home and
you're a [ __ ] strip club absolutely
not
yeah I think it's all time in place it's
the way that you ask but you you
definitely speak to your partner of
seven years about it yeah okay next one
tear toasters
I've been quarantine with my fiance at
his mom's house for the past month and
for the pet for the most part
everything's going great she's a little
older she's in her late 60's and tends
to be pretty conservative shockingly she
lets everything on Bravo's to be always
bond over our love of the shows during
quarantine we've been watching Beverly
Hills in New York together and there's
been a lot of talk about [ __ ]
sex etc she's always appalled by the
conversations and asking my opinion it
gets extremely uncomfortable because it
feels like she's directing the questions
to be about me and my fiance SEC sides
very awkward so awkward that it makes me
not want to watch and shows with her
anymore I don't want to come up as an
[ __ ] who doesn't want to hang out
with her since you this is the one thing
we really bond over she's also going
through a pretty tough time from trying
extra extra hard to be a good
daughter-in-law so I keep watching with
her and ride out these uncomfortable
conversations or do I act like a [ __ ]
and stop watching with her sincerely a
girl who doesn't want to talked about
feet about BJ's with her mother-in-law
ok um definitely keep watching with her
like it's a great bonding activity like
yes this is unfortunate but I don't
understand like the what is she trying
to get out of these conversations is she
like asking do you give the PJs and do
threesomes I think the vibe is like
she's trying to sniff out if like this
girl is like the housewives but you know
what a little white lie never went
anywhere just like pretend like you
think BJ's are gross and then walk back
to your room and give your man a [ __ ]
no but like then is she gonna be singing
wow she doesn't even give my son a
[ __ ] like but she said she's very
conservative ok so honestly just say
whatever you think she wants to hear
it's you know the conversation goes as
quickly and swiftly as possible I feel
like that is the complete right thing to
do like you're living in this woman's
house you don't need awkward moments and
you don't want to disrespect her so just
lie like sometimes lying is the best
yeah
say whatever you need to say all right
final one dear Claudia and Jackie hyd
love you both so much thanks for keeping
a smile on my face during these trying
times
I'm ready because I need some advice on
whether or not something is a
deal-breaker my boyfriend and I have
been together for about five years after
college I moved away from my family to
be closer to him
we've been quarantined together and it's
been great I finally want to head back
to my hometown to spend some quality
time with my family that I may never get
again because of quarantine and he and I
had planned to head back there for the
4th of July
he spent previous 4th of July's with my
family even Christmas but I've noticed a
bit of a pattern he'll commit to coming
home with me than a day before he'll
complain non-stop about having to travel
missing out on time with friends and
family
leaving me feeling really guilty and
making it seem like I'm making him spend
time with my family brother than him
just wanting to I'm extremely close with
my family and he is not at all with his
so his excuses that he just doesn't
understand the dynamic and why I want to
go home as often as I do but mind you I
really will only
to see my family three or four times a
year he swears he likes my family and
that they've been nothing but nice to
him but then outright say I would rather
go away with friends and hang with your
brothers and sisters why that's so mean
um I feel like every time I bring up
going to see my family he commits to it
but then finds an excuse to back out
it's exhausting and I feel like I
shouldn't have to convince him to do
something that brings me happiness he
now he knows how much my family means to
me to the point where discussing with
him makes me cry yet he doesn't budge is
this a red flag much love attire toaster
I mean this is my worst nightmare like
this yeah this is like hurting my head
in my heart
um but here's the thing I'm gonna put
myself in your situation thankfully like
obviously we love our family were always
like together and you know going on
trips and thankfully the boys had like
the that like brotherly relationship
where like they all take care of each
other and so it's not that dynamic but
like say we were always going places and
like doc didn't want to come he doesn't
wanna be with my family like blah blah
blah but I love being with my family and
I want to be there I'm going so like
yeah if that works for you to go by
yourself but some people like want their
partner to be with them all of the time
um so if that doesn't work for you then
that's a deal breaker for you it but
like I think that sometimes you should
just do the things that you want to do
and like if your partner should do what
they want to do and if it's not the same
thing like if it's a few days apart like
I don't think it's a big deal yeah this
really just depends on the type of
person like for me this is 100% a deal
breaker like my family is everything
they are my only friends like they're
the only people I ever hang out with the
only people I ever go on trip so it's
like to me this is a deal breaker so it
just it depends on who the person is and
what their priorities are but to have to
force someone to like be and it's just
honestly it sounds like you guys are so
different like you're so close with your
family like you value family and you
said that like he just does not he'd
rather hang out with his friends and his
family and like family's not a priority
for him so to me like the difference in
priorities might be a deal-breaker
um I don't know I don't want to tell you
to break up with him because you've been
together for five years but it seems
like he doesn't really appreciate the
fact that like you moved across the
country like for him yeah I agree if it
were us and like we spend all of our
time that would mean that I'm spending
no time with my partner if he doesn't
want to spend time with me when my
family but like some families like they
just go on like a few big like they go
Thanksgiving and there's a trip in like
that's
that's easy to work with so I think I
don't you figured out what your broker
yeah and like what your year-long
schedule looks like you know how many
times are you gonna be like doing
something with your family and is it
gonna be a fight with him like sometimes
it's just not worth the fight yeah and
then also like what do you want your
future to look like do you want like
your your kids to be really close with
your family because it's like it's it's
all fun and games now but like when you
have kids and then your husband doesn't
want to be with your family like kids
like if they have family around like
it's great cousins sounds like he's
being a little stubborn yeah like
everyone's sitting out with their
friends like this were sliding the
playground like urine it's like we're
adults now like come on yeah we're dulse
now we love our families that was deer
toasters please email us to your
toasters at gmail.com if you would like
to submit Shemin is here Oh a small
programming update from tienen r tienen
shows are all being released this week
but if you are looking for a new episode
of the snatchler today for the next few
weeks there will be a brief hiatus from
the snatchler you know the snack chiller
herself is just going through some stuff
and she wants to take some time off to
you know get her mental health and check
which is always important and self-care
is self-love and if you are struggling
with your mental health make sure to
take care of it so that's what the snaps
are doing
um so unfortunately there won't be
episodic of new TNN shows Margaret
Joseph's Lauren Elizabeth um Maternity
live is also not gonna be available this
week because she is busy pumping a pump
so listen to the toes listen to the news
network follow the twist news network on
Instagram and I think that's all that
she wrote did she text you and say
anything yes she said that her ear pods
are dying and so he's done writing
because she can't hear us anymore thank
you guys so much for listening to the
morning to us the millennium morning
show where we go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube so be watching us on YouTube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcast
we found so it Spotify iTunes stitcher
public radio I army to Cass pots all the
places where you listen to podcast find
us the Marny totally if I starve you
have it I beautiful setting as far we
are we love you guys so much have a
great table see you too mom
by